hi Matt here one area of study that
fascinates me is motivation a while back
I spoke with my colleague Suchi hang
about what helps us to get ourselves and
others motivated to initiate and
complete tasks I found our discussion
about needs and emotions really
interesting further sui shared ideas
about when it is useful to compare
ourselves to others I put some of her
advice to use in a friendly competition
where I and others are striving to be
more healthy and it really helped me to
achieve my goals so I invite you to
listen in to this think fast talk smart
best of episode on
motivation so much of our communication
is about motivation motivating others
and motivating ourselves I'm Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast I am really
excited to speak with sui hang an
associate professor of marketing at
Stanford GSB sui's research focuses on
motivation science and shared goal
Pursuit she studies things such as
competition healthy eating and dynamic
feedback hi sui welcome to the podcast I
am super excited to have you here thank
you Matt it's so good to be here
excellent let's go ahead and get started
in preparing to speak with you I
reviewed a lot of your work and I'm
struck by the variety of your research
from advertising to robots and goals in
competition I'm curious what motivates
the research you do yeah that is a great
question to start because definitely I
have pretty broad interest I actually
started getting intrigued by the topic
related to motivation because I was
working at an advertising agency JWT
back in Taiwan and at that time in
advertising the biggest question is how
do we motivate our customers to come
back to the store to purchase more
products and I realized we don't really
have a lot of answers about that and
that eventually motivated me to join
Academia and therefore I do a lot of
projects related to motivation and goal
Pursuit uh talking about how people's
motivation could change from one stage
to another or how we potentially
collaborate or compete when we are
working on goals together and then
because of that through my students I
started branching out to look at other
types of motivation such as how do we
motivate donors uh to donate money or to
volunteer and also looking at how new
technologies shape our motivation for
instance the use of fintech uh service
robots all these new technologies can
affect our motivation in the sense that
it can increase our motivation to do the
things we love or sometimes decrease our
motivation and that's why I started
looking into these other areas it it's
so exciting the things you study and I I
love that the story comes from your your
own curiosity and need when you were
doing advertising to see that we just
didn't know enough about motivation and
we'll get to talking about motivation
soon for sure we did a series of podcast
episodes where we talked about
communication and decision- making and
decision science with some of our GSB
colleagues and you teach a class and I
love the name it's called the brains and
guts of decisionmaking can you share one
or two key ideas that you cover in that
class definitely so the brands and guts
of decision making I teach that uh with
Jonathan laab so we are called directors
of the program so he takes care of the
brain part and I take care of the gut
part because I'm a motivation scientist
and the two main takeaways I have for
students in that class is the first
thing is that it's all about the needs
so in order to think about how we shape
people's behavior it's about
understanding what needs they have and
often times when we think about a
company or a product we kind of easily
zoom into one needs we believe people
have but it's actually way richer than
that so so I give an example of Nike
Nike sells shoes and shoes satisfy one
need physiological needs so we don't
have to hurt our foood when we walk but
of course that's way more than that Nike
also self self-esteem needs social needs
so you can jog with others share data
self-actualization needs because through
jogging you become fitter closer to your
ideal self so the needs can be all kinds
of needs and it's about picking up the
right motivation to speak to your target
audience so that's the first take away
uh usually I hope our students will have
the second one is closely tied to needs
and motivation is emotionality uh
because when our needs are satisfied we
get happy so there's a lot of positive
emotion there but when they're
dissatisfied that's when we get really
mad and grumpy so we have a lot of NE
negative emotion Recent research showed
that emotionality is really key in all
our decision- making uh researchers were
able to find that emotionality behind
the reviews actually account for way
more variance than the content of the
reviews so they were able to actually
link the emotionality behind the reviews
to predict the success of thousands of
movies billions of books and restaurant
reservations so it's not so much about
what the reviewers actually write about
but the emotionality behind their
reviews that drives uh people's decision
and so motivation emotionality these are
the two things I want to highlight wow
well when I look at my Nikey shoes
sitting in the corner and the fact that
I haven't run in them it sometimes makes
me feel bad but but I I I find that
fascinating so when we talk on this
podcast a lot about knowing your
audience and we talk a lot about their
needs and many of us when we start our
communication we start from the wrong
place we start from what do we want to
say rather than thinking about the needs
and what I like about what you've said
is you have to uncover all of the needs
it might just not just be one thing and
that's fascinating and the other aspect
you said about the emotionality so it's
not even so much what you say but it's
the emotion behind it that we're
decoding and reading and can be
motivational
really really interesting and I find
that to be true for myself when I when I
read a review of a restaurant or a book
I am taking away how did that person
feel about that definitely and it's
really fundamental because that's how
human beings connect and that's why we
categorize it as the gut reaction that's
a lot of times the key indicator of our
perception attitude and behavior oh
that's great and and Jonathan was on
recently and he he shared fantastic
insights too I can only imagine your
students take away amazing things from
both of you you also did research that
looked at what you call information
avoidance can you share what your
findings were and discuss how choosing
to avoid some information can affect our
motivation definitely this is actually
one of the most fascinating findings I
have uh discovered and also one of the
most personally relevant so in the
modern days we know we have all kinds of
social information I log into Facebook
Linkin Twitter Instagram I get to know
what all my friends and colleague are
doing and so it's really an era where we
have way more social information than we
need from the motivations perspective
what that means is we get all kinds of
social benchmarks we know how much
progress other people are making on
goals very similar to our own could be
house goals family time goals or career
goals and what we found in this research
is that we don't always want that
information so specifically when we are
starting to work on the new goal we love
that information because we want to
learn from what other people were doing
and we want to learn from their success
also as we get close to actually
reaching our goals we're usually feeling
great about ourselves so at that moment
we don't mind having those informations
because it could help us feel like we
are doing great and we are winning and
that feels great but what really is
critical is halfway through our goal
pursue process that is the moment where
we kind of we lose curiosity we don't
really feel we need to learn more about
the goal anymore we are not fully
confident that we can achieve our goal
yet so we are not in the late stage so
that halfway point is when we have a lot
of insecurity we are losing a little bit
motivation there and that moment we
don't want to know how well other people
are doing so that is when social
information becomes really threatening
and that is when we want to avoid it but
what we found is that if you give people
choice to actually avoid information
they can mute the notification move
their eyes away from the source of the
information what happens is they now
don't have the Benchmark that actually
motivates them so information avoidance
can actually lead to decreased
motivation and so after I found that I
use that piece of research to remind
myself so whenever I work on my goals
and I feel really stressed out and I
feel that other people are doing great
uh better than me I want to avoid the
information those are the moment I
realize actually I shouldn't be afraid I
should actually see those information
because that will give the Benchmark I
need to motivate myself to move forward
so that is kind of the key learning I
personally have from that research I so
relate to that be I I I'm by Nature I'm
a competitive person and when I I get
really excited with friends and others
and we're going to go embark on this if
it's if it's doing some kind of exercise
or losing weight and and after I've been
doing it a little while I do get that
insecurity like can I keep this up is it
going to go and then when I see my
friends making more progress and of
course they're very proud to share that
progress uh it makes me feel really bad
and and I do tune it out but what I'm
hearing you say is that I should go
against that desire to tune it out and
actually use it to keep that motivation
going what we found is that the moment
that we feel the most insecure about
having social information is the moment
where those information really is
valuable to have oh I love
counterintuitive things and I'm going to
try that because I'm I'm I'm got some
friends and we've got this little thing
around Health going on and I'm going to
I'm going to dive back in because i'
I've muted some of that information so
thank you for that we'll see I'll check
in with you in a little bit we'll see
how how much it help I look forward to
hearing your progress on that Matt okay
now I even more pressure it's all good
it's all good can you share what your
research suggests are some concerns and
best practices for Designing motivating
competitions so I have worked I more
directly look at actual competitions
zero some games where there is an
incentive or reward and you have to beat
others to get it and based on the
research we do know that Mo uh
competition definitely increases
motivation it make attaining the go more
valuable but what prior research hasn't
looked at is is it better to be ahead or
behind where you are in the competition
so we actually look at all kinds of data
sources from working out to class uh
performance and what we found is that
both winning or losing can motivate you
but they motivate you at different
phases of the competition so in the
beginning of the competition usually at
that moment we are looking for signal
that we can actually win so we're are
doing some kind of probability
assessment if there's no chance of
winning we would just disengage instead
of investing more resources into it so
this kind of a winning signal or feeling
that you are ahead is so helpful in the
beginning if you are already losing in
the beginning you will just give up but
winning signal doesn't always work as
you get closer to the late phase of
competition if you're still winning then
the natural tendency is you relax you
feel like you don't need to work hard
anymore and we forget about the fact
that this is not an individual goal it's
a competitive goal and you have no idea
what your opponent would do in that last
stage or last round of the game so
usually in the later phase being behind
slightly is actually way more motivating
because it give you a very clear
Benchmark to achieve so what do you do
if you're actually winning the whole way
through what we did in one of the
experiment is we actually ran a used
book donation Drive is a donation
competition across two campuses in China
so you naturally have a winning campus
that is doing well and a losing campus a
few weeks in they were collecting books
but not so great so what we did is of of
course we told the losing campus that
they are losing and they increase their
effort but we also want to motivate the
winning campus to continue donating used
books so what we did is we instead of
telling them they are winning we
compareed them to their campus's past
performance last year so yes you are
winning but comparing to how many books
you were able to raise last year you're
slightly behind of that Benchmark it is
a self- comparison Benchmark but turns
out even that comparison can be
meaningful to motivate the winning
campus to continue uh donating books so
that could be an important takeaway for
all of us who are listening to the
podcast who are winning right now it's
great to win and it sends a great signal
to help you stay motivated but if you
feel like you are actually demotivated
by that signal because it doesn't seem
that you need to put any more effort
maybe comparing to your past self could
be another way to motivate you well I
like I I really like that there are
different points of comparison and
different types of comparison to most
motivate and as people who design
competitions if you will we can actually
build in some of these metrics the
information that we give to people can
be really interesting I think of
Business Leaders who might be trying to
motivate internal teams or across
different companies how we might give
them feedback in a way that keeps
everybody motivated regardless of if
you're ahead or behind we actually talk
to uh companies a lot and also schools
you have uh students who are performing
well or self teams who are performing
well and you really don't want them to
relax they should try to achieve more
but you also can't take away the message
that they are indeed winning compared to
their peers so it is important to
actually change the Benchmark for those
people so they have something to strive
for right and and one other point you
made that really stuck with me is is if
you feel like you're losing early on you
just give up so that's an important
times period to give some motivational
feedback so that you can keep people
going because I've seen that happen I've
been an assistant coach on some of my
kids' teams or I've seen that in
companies where I've worked where if
people don't feel like they have the
skills right off the bat they just check
out that's why we always say that in the
early stage the most important signal is
attainability signal people need to
believe that the goal is attainable or
the competition is winable so they will
continue working hard and so like you
say we can't just think about giving the
same feedback to everybody for the
people who really need that
attainability signal we need to kind of
give them different feedback so that we
encourage them from the perspective that
yes what you have can actually help you
achieve the goal stop comparing to other
people maybe think about what the
ability you already have learned or
skills you have so like highlighting the
tenability is going to be critical in
the beginning and somehow creating that
Benchmark that uh additional goal to
strive for additional comparison to
strive for that would be important at
the end it's striking me in several
things that you've shared with us that
there are general principles but it
comes down to really tailoring your
motivational approach based on different
people's needs and their individuality
and I've heard you say that several
times and I think that's a really
important takeaway for all of us is that
there General guiding principles but
what you know about the individual or
the team really drives the tailored
communication that you have to them the
biggest part of my research finding is
on the temporal dynamics of goal pursue
and the important aspect of this is in
the past we tend to think about what
motivates people as a static thing so if
I figure out one variable one factor I
just give that to everybody but the
temporal Dynamics model say that it
should be dynamic the feedback we give
people should be dynamic depending on
who they are what skills they think they
have and where they come from and also
as they make more progress during a
competition or pursuing their personal
goal the feedback should be dynamic as
well we can't keep on giving them the
same kind of signal so changing that and
teor that for everybody's needs is going
to be critical in sustaining motivation
so this is a beautiful transition to
another question I have for you which is
this notion of what I hear you say is
your feedback has to be different based
on where people people are in their
journey and I know you along with our
colleague Jennifer AER have done some
research into how having a mindset a
journey mindset can actually really
influence how you achieve goals would
you share more about that study I found
this really fundamentally changing for
me personally it was personal for me too
uh that research finding has a lot of
relevance for how I think about success
and definitely the motivation for that
work it came from the fact that we tend
to think about go success as a
destination we reach a dination and we
feel great but what happen when you
reach the destination is that there's
nothing else left to be done right so a
lot of times people graduate and they
stop learning or they lose weight and so
they stop working out and F
fundamentally we want people to continue
learning and continue working out or
monitoring what they eat those good
behaviors should continue so what we
found in this research is that it is
important to think about goal success
not just as a destination but also as a
journey it doesn't actually have have to
be a journey Forward Thinking about the
next goal but it's actually more
important to use it as a journey look to
Look Backwards to look at what you have
done right during this process that help
you achieve the goal who were
instrumental for you during this journey
well I've enjoyed this very much before
we end I'd like to ask you the same
three questions I ask everyone who joins
me is is that okay with you great then
let's get started if you were to capture
the best communication advice you've
ever received as a five to seven-word
presentation slide title what would it
be it actually already came up earlier
in our talk and I just need three words
know your audience we have heard that a
lot on this podcast and it and what you
bring to that is really a lot of depth
and richness so it's about emotionality
it's about understanding that audiences
aren't homogeneous that there there's
differentiations and Nuance in there and
and to know that they evolve they will
change right over over time that Journey
that's so important it's not static
excellent thank you who is a
communicator that you admire and why I
have to say Michelle Obama and I think
every time I hear her speak there are
four things that comes to mind Clarity
confidence elegance and empathy and I
think a speech that has all four
elements are very powerful absolutely uh
and and you role model some of that
yourself I mean the clarity of the
information the the Elegance of the
research that you've done that excellent
choice number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe so the
first one I have to come back to the
same point know your audience
specifically know why they are there to
listen to the message and the second one
will be to tailor your content
connecting your account content to that
audience and the third one make it
personal you also have to connect the
content to you so you're not just lectur
ing something that they can hear from
anybody else they're actually learning
specifically from you all three of those
are critical I I want to put an
exclamation point after that personal
part because I think that's something
that we don't think about and sometimes
people don't feel comfortable doing but
it really does make a difference if you
feel that the person has a direct
connection to that content it's
meaningful to them thank you for
reminding us of that that's that's
really really
important well thank you sui this has
been wonderful you have certainly
motivated me to be more interested in
motivation I love your research and how
it covers so many different areas and
really makes us think about who we're
talking to when we're talking to them
and how we can motivate our audience
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me
Matt you've been listening to think fast
talk smart the podcast a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business
this episode was produced by Michael
Riley Jenny Luna and me Matt Abrahams
find more resources and join our
conversation on LinkedIn by searching
think fast talk smart please download
And subscribe wherever you get your
podcasts